you can tell right now he wants to get
some layups
cavs eight straight losses by an average
of 126 to 104
as murray is away jay defensively as we
see murray
kind of going to work and watch now
joker comes allen has to leave that
double team
an improved offensive player 90 to 78
murray straight away
again so murray is flurrying
here in the third quarter cleveland
doesn't think that
truman's 2020 games are productive
long range murray again blue
arrow strikes and murray goes and gets
it murray playing
a terrific all-around game so far
tonight heat check
for murray oh my goodness oh my
jamaal murray
well that's a quick shot three because
he sees the defender
and i told you before the game i'll take
the loss
nuggets have the steal yokish in
overdrive over to murray he sets he
fires
he gets the triple and dances
trying to clear some space
[Applause]
[Music]
oh by murray for
50. let me get 50 with the dunk
oh
as good as it gets jamal murray the
first time he's ever had
50 in a regular season game which will
count
for his career high
well nothing like getting 50 but now
you're getting 50 almost missed that
dumb